in this video I want to do a
demonstration of the process of labeling
voltages on a circuit that we're about
to analyze this is something that
sometimes causes stress or confusion and
I want to just basically try to get out
of that stressful situation so the first
thing I want to do is remind ourselves
of the the convention the sign
convention for passive components so we
said if we have a resistor that we draw
this way and we label the voltage plus
or minus V on it then when we label the
current arrow we want to label the
current arrow so it goes into the
positive terminal of the component in
this case a resistor so just another
quick example if I draw the resistor
sideways like this if I label the
voltages the minus one on this side and
the plus one on this side then when I go
to apply the current arrow
I put the current arrow into the
positive voltage sign so this this here
is the sign convention for an individual
component how do we label the voltage
and the current together to be
consistent now we're going to go over
and analyze a circuit I've drawn to a
circuit here it's two identical circuits
and we're going to do it two different
ways with two different voltage labels
so the first thing we do of course when
we analyze a circuit is we we set up the
variables that we want to talk about so
we'll do this side first I'll label this
is I and that's that's a choice I can
make
and then I'm going to label the voltages
too and I'm going to choose to label the
voltages like this plus and minus V and
we'll call this v1 and this will be plus
or minus v2 so first let's carry through
and do the analysis of this circuit and
I'll give some component values to this
will call this 10 ohms and this one's 20
ohms
now I'm going to do an application of of
Kirchhoff's voltage law around this loop
and we'll see how it turns out
all right so Kirchhoff's voltage law
will start at this node here and we'll
go around the circuit this way and we'll
do some equations we'll say plus three
volts when we go through this device we
get a voltage rise of three then we get
a voltage drop because we go from plus
to minus we get a voltage drop of minus
v1 and then we get another voltage drop
of v2 minus v2 equals zero that's our
KVL equation for this circuit over here
so let's keep going with this analysis
three volts minus v1 is I times r1 I
times 10 and v2 is I times 20 ohms and
that equals zero so let's keep going 3
minus I times 10 plus 20 equals zero and
that means that I equals minus 3 over
minus 3 goes to this side 10 plus 20 is
30 and the minus sign goes with the 30 -
30 so I equals minus you're sorry I
equals plus amp so we solved for I and
let's go solve let's just pick out v1
let's solve for v1 and we said earlier
that v1 was I times r1 so v1 equals I
which is 0.1 amps times 10 ohms equals 1
volt
if we do it for v2 that equals 0.1 amps
times 20 ohms and that equals 2 volts
and I can do one last little check I can
go back and I can see KVL I can do a
check to see if this equation came out
right so 3 volts minus v1 is 1 volt and
v2 is 2 volts and that equals 0 and I
get to put a checkmark here because yes
it's equal to zero so that was a real
quick analysis of a simple 2 resistor
circuit and we got all the voltages and
currents now I'm going to go do the same
thing again but this time I'm going to
do the voltage labels a little bit odd
okay what I'm going to do here is I'm
going to say 2 plus I'm going to define
v1 to be in that direction and we'll
keep v2 like it was before and now I
need a current variable and I'm going to
call my current variable I here just
like we did before now at this point you
might say Willy you did it wrong you did
it wrong that's not the right voltage
label but I want to show you that I'm
going to get the same answer even though
I did it this unusual way so let's do
the same KVL analysis on this circuit
and what I want to show you is that the
arithmetic that we're about to do takes
care of the signs just fine alright so
KVL on this circuit says that we'll
start at the same place and go around
the same direction so this says that 3
volts voltage rise of 3 volts we go in
the minus sign and out the positive sign
so that's a voltage rise and now we get
over to r1 and we go in the minus sign
of r1 and out the plus sign so that's
plus v1 that's different than we had
last time right last time we had minus
v1 here see and now we have plus v1 this
is going to work out ok though now we
have we go in the plus sign of v2
and we come out to minus sign so that's
a voltage drop so we do a subtraction
and that equals zero all right we got
different equations but we have
different definitions of v1 so now I
want to write these V terms in terms of
the resistance value and the current
value and this is where we use the sign
convention carefully
so now we need to include a term to
represent our one to use Ohm's law here
now we have to be careful this is one
point we have to be careful the current
is going in the negative terminal of r1
so we're going to say V r1 equals
negative I times R one that makes sense
if we define our current variable to be
going in the negative sign then Ohm's
law picks up this negative sign to make
it come out right so down here we plug
in minus I R 1 which is minus I times 10
that's a difference and then we go
through V 2 and V 2 is the same as it
was in the other equation minus V 2 is I
times R 2 which is 20 and that all
equals zero so even right now if you
look at this equation you see this minus
sign that's snuck in here because of our
good use of the sign convention for
passive components that makes this
equation look just like this one here so
let's continue with the analysis just
need a little bit more room 3 volts
minus I times 10 plus 20 equals 0 now we
have the same equation at 2 4 so we're
going to get the same I I equals 3 goes
to the other side becomes minus 3 10
plus 20 is 30 with the minus sign it
goes over
same as before
so those came out the same so now let's
go check the voltages see if we can
compute the same voltages and what we
have to notice here that our reference
direction the original reference
direction we have four V generated a
minus sign when we used Ohm's law so we
keep doing that it's okay so v1 equals
minus I R 1 equals minus 0.1 amps times
10 and that equals minus 1 volt and V 2
equals I times R 2 which is equal to 0.1
times 20 ohms and that equals plus 2
volts and now the difference we see the
difference here here is the difference
that showed up V 1 in this circuit has
the positive voltage at the top it came
out with a value of plus 1 volt and when
we flipped over V 1 negative 1 volt here
means that this terminal of the resistor
is 1 volt below this terminal of the
resistor and that means exactly the same
thing in this case as it does in this
case so these two things mean the same
thing and of course the voltage number 2
came out the same so the purpose of the
demonstration was just to show you that
no matter which way you name the
voltages somewhere in here like right
here kirchoff's voltage law will take
care of keeping the sign right and you
end up with the same answer at the end
so when you're faced with a problem of
labeling a circuit like this don't
stress out about trying to guess ahead
what the sign of the voltage is going to
turn out you just need to pick an
orientation and go with it and the
arithmetic will take care of the
positive signs and the negative signs